when I first met this one I saw rose and
I latched on to her I told her baby I
don't want to marry I just want to be
your man Rose told me I told him if he
wasn't a man kind and move out the way
so the marrying kind confine me that's
what she doing in my way you're blocking
the view move out the way so I can find
me a husband wait Cory I want him to
help me with this fence he got recruited
by a college football team it ain't
gonna get him nowhere if he'd be like
you in the sports he gonna be alright
okay but two men never played baseball
good as you and what it ever give me I
ain't got a pot to piss in or a window
to throw it out of hey pop can I ask you
a question how come you never liked me
what law is there say I got to like you
a man is supposed to take care of his
family
you live in my house for your belly with
my fool
put your behind on my bed because you're
my son
now don't you go through life worrying
about whether somebody like you or not
you best be making sure they're doing
right by you or just trying to fill out
your shoes I don't want him to be like
me I want him to get as far away from my
life as he possibly can get you'd only
decent thing about nummy rolls you can't
be nobody for who you are Troy that's
all you got to measure yourself against
the world out there why you ought to
know always Tyler know whoever give me
your feet their bones an open heart
you've never done that the behold me
back afraid I was gonna be better than
you
everything that boy do he do for you
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place for 18
years I've been standing with you I got
a life too don't you think I had dreams
and hopes what about my life what about
me
some people build fences to keep people
out and other people build fences to
keep people in house you put a cell on
the end of it when you talk to me yes
sir you eat every day yes sir got a roof
over your head yes sir got clothes on
your back yes sir why you think that is
cuz he hell I know it's cuz of me but